take another bite show me it's real
yeah you know
um
that wasn't fake no special effects she
loves that's not fake
[Music]
for some people pizza is all about
following the rules and coloring inside
the lines but for others a slice can be
infinitely customizable a blank canvas
to showcase personal taste and
creativity i look for voids and i try to
fill them there's no soft shell crab
pizza so i had to go deep into my little
mind and invent that today we're
ditching the kitchen to head to my
backyard in rockaway queens well i'll be
facing off against rapper turned chef
mayhem lorraine may him and i are just
freestyling it today these are the
flavors and ingredients we love to put
on a pie but will they hit for peace
appearance like frank and joe mayhem's
up first
we've got mayhem lorena in the building
queen's in the building queens get the
money what's going on how you doing very
well now that you're here okay so what
we got going on today soft shell crab
pizza something simple something light
you know
soft shell crab pizza so mayhem i hear
you're a huge seafood guy when did that
love affair of seafood start for you
when i was like three years old i fell
off a boat i got bitten by a crab and i
struck back so i ended up eating what
tried to eat me is that a real story nah
that sounds good right
all right let's go what you got going on
step one is you have to stare at the
dough with lust in your eyes so it knows
it's real i i cheated actually i put i
put this in a round bowl because i'm not
a pizza professional i'm just a guy who
knows how to cook pizza that's okay so
it's easier for me to stretch the dough
when i already let it take a circular
form
you know i'm gonna generously apply some
pesto damn i have bees here my least
favorite insect is here haunting me as
we do this shoot it's okay it's all
right i got you i love that i love the
colors you got over there the green is
so beautiful
yeah we're out here looking like
christmas looking like christmas or a
pair of gucci sneakers
okay we got the pesto what's next i'm
gonna go directly with the the provolone
you're so fancy over there this is an
expensive pie i like provolone over
mozzarella just because it's you know
it's just a little sharper it's
something different it just you know
kicks it up a notch
lump jumbo crab meat real not imitation
somebody gives you imitation crab meat
you immediately harm them
that's it for now honestly we're going
to add some things in a second i'm going
to put this in for around two minutes
pull it out rotate it then i'm gonna add
some things when i put it back in oh so
you're gonna like garnish it yep okay
cool
[Music]
it's all about color i needed to get a
good color a good texture i needed to
look like it just came from venice beach
what's cool about the unicoda is an
l-shaped flame you want to always turn
your pie
you know towards getting it brown
towards the flame
but you don't need any help look at that
oh i'm excited we're adding some roasted
garlic right now couple cloves you know
if you get a clove it's like you won the
lottery we can't forget the star of the
show you're putting whole crabs on the
pizza it's a soft shell crab in the
middle i love that we're gonna take this
calabrian spread really it's just
calabrian chilies olive oil in a food
processor and then we're gonna put this
back in for around a minute so how are
you feeling about your chances today i
mean i'm feeling good i'm a confident
human but you should either way we both
win just cause just cause we're up here
yeah playing with soft shell crab yeah
we already won i agree you know let's go
that roasted garlic's getting extra
roasted right now and there's color on
the sides it's everything oh my god
that's so beautiful
i'm just getting started
oh
my gosh that's gorgeous
just a little olive oil on it whoo
let's go i'm just trying to get you a
piece whatever yeah give me a little bit
of you know what this looks like up the
best pieces oh thank you so much quick
cheers all right okay
cheers to you
[Music]
oh my god
mayhem i just think this is awesome the
flavors are impeccable out of this world
you could tell you put a lot of care
into all the different combinations you
know you got a little bit of heat but
it's not overbearing i think you did a
phenomenal job and your bake your bake
is out of sight i appreciate what i'm
saying i mean that's due to the oni yeah
i can't take the credit for what the oni
did take another bite show me it's real
take another bite yeah you know
[Music]
that wasn't fake no special effects she
loves that it's not fake it's not fake
at all now i'm ready to see what you're
gonna do
hope you like it i'm sure i will
[Music]
mayhem your pizza was amazing
and i'm truly inspired by what you did
you know one of the things when i
started last dragon pizza i wanted my
pizza to be like the flavors of new york
so what we have is the infamous
pastrami smoked salmon from rust and
daughters i'm gonna just create a pie
that reminds you of like cat's daily
russian daughters the legends
and i hope you enjoy it it's all love
here but this is also a pizza warren i
feel she's coming at me kind of crazy
right now so stefan i'm just going to
open my dough up and i get it to a good
size this is a good size for the colder
16. so i just put some of my marinara
down we're gonna add some mozzarella i
gotta do the mozzarella so now i'm gonna
put down some cherry tomatoes because
there's nothing like baked cherry
tomatoes on a pie i'm sorry
and i'm also going to put down some raw
onions i'm going to put some capers
this is war coming at me crazy right now
hey you know we both knew yorkers we got
to represent and like the crust to
really make it feel like a bagel i got
everything seeds all around i saw you do
that
paying attention this is looking good so
far we got the unicode 16 right here
nice and hot ready to go i'm gonna pop
this in
[Music]
[Applause]
okay there we go
i am going to take some arugula that i
have a little bit of olive oil shaved
parmesan black pepper salt and now the
main event
i'm putting my scallion cream cheese
stuffed
pastrami smoked
lox
on each slice i'm a gentleman it's
usually ladies first but i need to take
this bite right now i'm sorry cheers
[Music]
so mayhem what do you think
a picture's worth a thousand words an
empty place worth two you know
each flavor complemented each other you
know you have two layers of red onions
same thing with the tomatoes you know
arugula olive oil like you you taste it
all it all came together like seriously
if you turned your head real quick i'd
grab another slice
mayhem you ready to go to the judges
table let's go we out let's go
all right joe
look at this one i know this looks
really interesting this is one of the
most interesting pieces i i think i've
ever laid eyes on
soft shell crab pizza
with chili
garlic parmesan are you done because i
don't like my pizza cold
hamuni
i love this i i mean i really love this
i'm tired of the same old flavors i'm
tired of just tomatoes the mozzarella
half the time people don't use the right
ingredients
or the best that they can
and this is like
it's creative you're a traditionalist i
know that i already i see the look on
your face and you're saying to yourself
what is it well i'll tell you my parents
come from sicily so i love seafood i
could eat seafood all day any day so i'm
really appreciating something different
at the moment i definitely think that
the crust is nice as a nice consistency
it's chewy which goes really well with
the crab and the sauce i'm really liking
provolone there's a little sharp edge to
it i always try to guess who may have
made the pizza you know in my head
and this pizza screams out to me swag it
screams out to me creativity the problem
is
is that both pizza makers today you know
have those characteristics so
it's going to be a tough one all right
frank i'm on my second slice but we got
to make room for the next pizza you
ready i don't know i think i'm going to
have one more of these i really like
this all right you better save room for
the next one that's all i'm saying i'll
have somebody i'm going to finish this
right now
joe this is our second pie
it kind of looks like an everything
bagel a little bit i see some sea salt
on there pastrami cured salmon cream
cheese is this sort of like along the
lines of jewish cuisine deli style
something like that maybe i don't know
but it's really good i can't talk right
now
it's light
airy flavorful
it has so many different elements
there's mozzarella which makes the pizza
arugula my favorite
some tomatoes which has a little
sweetness to it
tapers are a little salty and you taste
it in one bite which is what you want on
a pizza all right joe i know you love
this one the other pizza blew my mind i
think we gotta sit down and talk it out
and uh hopefully we won't end up boxing
like we did last time yeah i mean i'm
ready to choke you out again but
[Music]
mayhem nicole
these two pizzas were
fantastic you really did a number today
i mean we had such a hard time trying to
figure this one out like i said we both
won already you know i believe that too
we both winners let's go so the first
pie that we had
blew my mind i've never seen a pizza
like this the way that it was made was
really flavorful it was almost like
there was a dry rub or something on the
softshell crab there was nice chunks of
meat flavor was fantastic and the
creativity
won me over so this second part right
here it just reminds me of like having
brunch with my my mother and my sisters
but the best part about it was it was a
pizza and it was so new york with that
whole everything seasoning just to top
it all off we have like a nice burnt
crust but i found this pizza to be
fantastic you know mayhem and i we
worked really hard which pie gets the
trophy
both of these pies had so many great
qualities to him
we couldn't make up our minds so for the
first time ever
it's a tie
[Applause]
wow
where's the pizza cutter let's cut the
trophy in here
you guys both just knocked it out of the
park um i don't know if they told you a
piece of words but when there's a tie
forfeits to me
you take the trophy i'll take the onions
i'll worry let's go
that sounds like a good title for a song
or an album man
load the truck up
[Music]
you